[Music]
this could be the warm savannahs of
Africa instead it's the open grasslands
of Texas finn's ten properties of the
fossil rim Wildlife Center it's home to
both the black and white African rhino
both endangered species black rhinos
came to fossa rim in 1992 as a
cooperative effort with the government
of Zimbabwe and what we tried to work
out at that point was there was there
was poaching in Africa they were
concerned about losing all of their
rhinos and so the animals that came to
the United States were basically an
insurance policy against extinction this
Conservation Center in Glen Rose Texas
has been breeding rhinos ever since in
2001 they celebrated a new arrival
this is COO simona
a 2,500 pound black rhinoceros his
father was sent from fossil rim to
Australia to help a breeding program
there and now COO simona his son has
come home
after a long flight coup Simona is ready
for his new quarters and after exploring
them a bit
he's ravenous after 30 days in
quarantine
hi Simona is free to breed with the
female rhinos here at the centre the
real significance to bringing us this
new bowling is that he's totally
unrelated to any other animals in this
country he's brand new bloodline the
Bulls new bloodline will diversify the
rhino population creating a stronger
gene pool and increasing the populations
resistance to disease but more
importantly COO Simona will add a few
new additions to the population here
humans are the adult rhinos only
predator in the wild black rhinos are
killed in Africa for their valuable
horns which are sold as decorations
medicinal cures and aphrodisiacs
since 1970 their numbers have dropped
more than 95% because of habitat loss
and poaching the future of this animal
is really in the hands of human beings
and if we don't move aggressively we
could lose this endangered species and
of course many others at the faucet rim
Wildlife Center both humans and rhinos
are doing their best to keep the species
alive in 2005 kusa Mona's son was born
106 pounds of baby black rhino